[Applause]
you are very cute and beautiful T today
look we didn't even call each other yes
you were feeling Earth Tones I was
feeling how are your chickens last time
you were here we were talking about your
chickens let's get to the serious stuff
get right to the nitty gritty yes well
um the chickens moved to the family farm
in Oklahoma oh my bunnies I talked to
you about now live in Montana my my
Ranch in Montana okay yes it's better
for them they're happier yeah and yes
each of them went and I felt a little
bit guilty about this but each of them
went in their own little Togo box I was
a little bit like don't think too much
about this chicken you're not nuggets
it's not a nugget and they all had a
little bit of food on the plane with a
little bit of benad dril in
there but this a tiny bit of um I love
that though that's fun living on a farm
that's better they are they they don't
lay eggs anymore they're post menopausal
um but you know what they
I know but they still have value and
they're still smart lovely ladies they
are
[Music]
[Applause]
relevant thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home